こんにちははず店像です今日は子供の日子供が好きな食べ物と来たらまずこちらが
上がるだろう
tery スプレーた読者住田町南山をおじいちゃんと類推見た目もおじさんなんです
けども心は全然子供なんですよね
ここら子供の大の大人が本気でねぇカレーライスを食べたいと思ったところ
なぜ今回約40万円のカレー作ってもらいました
こちらー
テイクアウトであのご時世で限定カードを作って頂きました
こちらです4じゃないのかえして
すごくねしかも静岡のカツカレーのジャイアンというお店があるんですけどそこの店長
さんに作って頂きました40万円をカレーで高い支えられて調べた熱気のまま幻だ
みたいな買って売ってないんですよ本当にと苦痛で塩とになんとかして高くて勉強に音
がレイライスを作ってくださいっていう値段味
もうコツパターンが導入や決意相撲コストなしあもうなんだけど
充電多いで作ってもらったカレーがこちらになります専用の来週まで付いております東
と鳥取あえて変えてみましょう
みてくださいテイクアウトの底からはみ出てるんですよね男女する事言ってはみ出ん
ばかりの洋上になってしまったんでしょう早速40万円よくでれっ開けてみようと思い
ます
もう尊びお花とか金髪が弾いてるんですけどもこれどうな
てるでしょ中身上げます
もう見えてるんだけどね
まあ
すごいすげー緊迫するここだけでした分もん山陽線するんだろうないやーもうなんかす
えええええ
5i とりあえず飾りのお花はいいかなちょっとすごいいい感じでお肌のてますけどせ
ませんこれは玉鷲に関係ないと思うので撮っちゃいますよ室よりまずはなにはともあれ
ご飯がちょっと特別なんですけども
うん
ヒューマンスをもご飯のクオリティーが凄いつももう色々乗ってますけどもとりあえず
ご飯だけも作っちゃいました機で建てるご飯街らしいから自分で炊くんだって
3なかった方のみお水よいい感じに水が入ったんで
+きましたよしってそうですこれで20分ほどたきますって言ってる間に
このカレーライスの紹介でも行きましょうか罪状でキャビアに
裏太陽のタマゴマンゴールビーロマンクラウンメロンピン5
金箔熊野てバニック近いに行く欲しい我孫子市な魔法鰹節昆布牛の骨髄万事の玉ねぎ
ドライトマトバター青森産のニンニクしょうがスパイスチーズ来数が痛い40万くらい
で売られるのかなというふうなんでございますその値段の内訳いますねこれがキャビ
はですねキャリア愛とロシアから取り入れた高級キャビアで一番に生らしいです
[音楽]
風邪となく不待って何が北海道の高級にで一番3年
いくらがちょっと何も帰ってないって点つ覚えてるんですけどもだいたい件3人組する
あのこれらのほんのちょっとの両横のようで1300円とかです多分宮がすごい
フルーティにされている部長マンゴー1万円クラウドへの5000円ルビーロマン
10,000円金箔でだいたい5万円ぐらい着らしいですレッスンにキンキラしている
も
熊野ってです9魔の手が50,000円
なんかに混んでるうちに溶けちゃったらしいです北海道のツキノワグマの左照らせて
含まって右手の発熱食べるらしいの右手が美味しいっておいてるんですけども
ゴルゴ13は左手で獲物を捕らえるから左手の方が美味しいというはてひどいらしいで
少ないが5万馬が7000出荷が5000円ってナマコが入ることによってとみおま
知ってちょっとクリーミーな感じに仕上がってるらしいです凝ってるなテゴちゃんと
いい感じに美味しそうな気がしてきますあなたが10万円
星良子で2万円活動星市場へ今まで御茶に入った黒のヘッドですとアーチ型の的に
1000円物証こそで4000 l ドライバと実践円高い食材をそれぐらいですねで
ボロボロでだいたいこんなんですねクマンの手下中ドンペリドンペリのロゼに
つけたんで今までだけで12さんなんかメットよし行ったらどうせなので5万するんで
今履いてるを込めバスなっていないすっていうインドの家庭なんですけどインドだと
古い奥目の方が高級らしいんですね大外でも日本の大お米の2倍くらいするって何とか
ミート統一の普通のお米の半分ぐらいというよろしいですそしてなんとばニックと鹿肉
はもう生でも食えるぐらい良いものを使う
てるらしいですまぁ大体こんな感じですねあともう盛りだくさん過ぎてスゴいんだけど
でちょっと装って言っちゃいます
うんすごいもうなんか結構盛りたくさん入れてくれたんで相当入ってるのは金は付属の
トッピングがえげつないけどほぼ金箔これがウニかな
チックに乗せてきます
テロともともうわぁないやばいったじゃん
榮倉というかキャビア4
なんとなくのライズの子立よってきましたでは line しても載せていきましょう
ua
こんなナイスまじアンマー見たことない
明らかに我々がいつも日本の食べてないさあ違うことがはっきりとこの日に見て分かり
ますそしてバターが乗っていていろんな変化がべも c です黄色い
黄色いライスが今工芸そうなステンレスのフルートに今しっかりと思っていくいいいい
感じなのではないでしょうか
今食べてる状態にたどり着きました
未加入ですこちらがー
あっあっあっなんということでしょう
英高級の素材最高級の b
最高級のスパイス最高級の海鮮
すべてがまとまった最高の金の完成です
いや私は盛り付けただけなんですけども配当がいよいよ完成しました40万円だかいい
本当にちょっとおっ
まぢからさすがにこの値段のカレーはもう空ことないでしょいっしょ
体カードでもここまでできるんかっていうね今とタブ t カードでコンピューターの
史上初2な気がします食べてみましょう
g
いただきます
緊張するなもう普通に
ずキャビアと売りと行くのしっかり混ぜて回線の範疇だしつつ
とカチッ口に入れてみようとしましょういただきます
[音楽]
ちょっとちょっと表現に時間がかかりますよですね
えっ
うーんまあお茶目さん
あの何がうまいか分からんけどなかったら運はどうかが実用こうなんと言えばいいん
でしょ
適切な表現法がわからないんですけどもええ
うまいよ普通にびっくりするぐらい関係ないと綴ってる気がしますね味がニックもね
なんか柔らかいお肉ているた町家眠たいのあるって恋噛み心地の良い肉が入って行って
やってばご飯ですね右腕がやっぱ特殊じゃないす使ってるか知らないんですけど軽いん
ですよ
もちもち感金なんか刺さるファーするっていうかない溶けそうしたは-1カロリーも
低いでしょもう最高ですよこれルーの味です
すごい普通のレースに伝わですかなという気がしますめっちゃ真面目にコメントします
けど本当に高すぎるのでちょっと伝えられる形の方だったりたいと思います宜しくお
願いします改正がやばい海が本当にいい味出してたんだと
を阻止や羽根 ze くらたまないですからねそんな俺が進んで食うぐらいの何か良い
マッチングなんですよね
以上前に初めていただきますあのねぇ
本当に上手い表現し葛混ぜて食べてる奴にちょっと線
混ぜて食うのはうまいと思うよねちょっと絵面的にはアレですけどいただきます
[音楽]
やすげー
お腹いっぱいですねなんかこれあるあるだと思うんですけども高級品ってすごいお腹歩
くれません
ちょびっとの量でマットになっちゃうようまいんではでね今お前よねまずは強いかなり
しますよ
お腹さんいきますまあ
じゃあ一回に5月てもらってすぐすごいはすごいます
はぁやります今でよっ
[音楽]
あー
よいざ
を高生上部本当に俺もファクターがあるね来てくださいじゃないですよ
運命を除くいただきます
おやつどうぞダンカン来ちゃってください
うんっ
ん
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
ゾイド
別のですかやってるんです4ルマン40万ちょい悪そう
えっ
めっちゃもソウルっ子チョッパ doodle すげーキャビア padi もふー
うードゥ
まえないじゃなにこれずっと増えたんだっけなまあ今井正
てこれ40万ないあっどうぞ
食べてくださいこれクッキー柄どうぞ
[音楽]
ん
いただけますよねばっっ
よす
とった
やってました馬僕はスペース汚れを難なくてきたい方は防げるという
どうですか
まあ大
持っ
黒坂40万円です
ゆんですよぜよ羽幌
タブっていうか音符レースはどんどん
ゾン中
どうぞめっちゃ食ってもらい不安ですか
なんかミクの食感がすごい弾力があって
なんか消しゴム食べているみたい